buongiorno e bentornati a una nuova
puntata del blog ma in realtà mamma mia
una madonna dicevo in realtà sono
abbastanza di fretta perché devo andare
alla laurea di mio cugino e aspetta te
sto facendo un paio di check e sono
fondamentalmente già in ritardo perché
mi sono fatto un bagno di un'ora e mezza
se avessi messo fiamme 2 zucchine una
carota avrei fatto pure er brodo il
grande problema adesso è vestirsi perché
si sta laureando in giurisprudenza e
tutti quanti stanno dicendo che bisogna
vestirsi fondamentalmente eleganti io
odio il termine elegante perché ci sono
un sacco di in se non e sfumature di
eleganza cioè potreste essere col
papillon e il frac come potresti essere
un dolcevita nero a collo a se c'è un
dolce vita c'era il collo alto quindi
alla fine ho concordato che il mio grado
di eleganza sarà 7,5 ma non so a cosa
corrisponde 7,5 partiamo sicuramente la
calzini neri che non si sbaglia mai
al posto dei soliti pantaloni quelli che
ne sono un po e li cantini non ammettere
questi vi faccio vedere che poi in
realtà sono difficili si lamenta perché
mi state leggermente stretti su curato
ok entrati a forza non so se si vedono
ma sono un po come spiegarvelo mamma al
settimo mese di gravidanza
pantalone che mi vado a impreziosire con
questa scarpa versatile è che è una
dottor martin o martens dottor marty
molto attuale martins e ragazzi che
hanno scelto bene dottor qualcosa credo
sia con la s dal discorso sotto è
abbastanza semplice anche perché non è
che abbia vive il sopra è un pochino più
complesso perché non so in che direzione
in che direzione io voglio andare e
adesso scopriremo un pochino insieme
speriamo ci siano cadaveri ho scheletri
penso che li porti tutti di schede
all'arno negli ormai potrei andare o con
una camicia con una camicia nera proprio
nel secondo con una cosa così che in 2
secondi e proprio mito cantonese
mitrovica all you can eat ma ci può
stare un twist nuovo diverso
sono stanco di queste giacca e cravatta
non so quanto si veda perché soprattutto
nero ma sono diventato charlie chaplin
non lo so perché luigi non mi risponde
al telefono che molto probabilmente sta
in palestra e visto che lui e la sua
pausa pranzo se la fa in palestra
povero pazzo c'è qualcosa che urla moda
chiaramente qualcos'altro lui ammette
quindi sco sto cercando di capire quale
voce ascoltare manca un dettaglio manca
qualcosa che cosa manca un qualcosa che
rosea ma rosa non è fiammifero e della
benzina un sorriso lo sto controllando
nel cassetto degli accessori che mi ha
obbligato sempre luigi a creare un paio
di occhiali neri sicuramente li metto
quindi omettere le lenti a contatto casi
no sembra poi padrino no mammamia zero
come pochi aspettate questa mare galata
luigi faccio l'esperimento allora prima
di giudicare fatemi spiegare al posto
della cravatta mi vado a mettere una
catenina con un crocifisso allora i
capito una cosa che più lo guardo più po
mi fa schifo e più vuol dire che forse e
moda perché riconosco quello schifo
strano della moda però io sicuramente
poi avrò il feedback di luigi che mi
dirà che faccio pagare però è anche
immagino quello vostro faremo sapere qua
sotto
cioè in moda on air questo tocco un
pochino dei bocelli e ci sta ok il look
è finito sembra mettere altra mio the
matrix un pappone e un vampiro
fatemelo sapere davvero ci tengo nodo me
not one ora devo dì può correre perché
sono in ritardo ma devo portare anche un
regalino che gli volevo fare in generale
che era lui visto che un fan sfegatato
di questo gioco e che altro mi porto la
roba per girare il blog max che se
rimaniamo senza schede cose così vv
quanto sta occupando bravo guglielmo che
per le ad alta voce da solo come pazzi
la pazzia aiuta come ho detto ciao
[Applauso]
ma tengo secolo magnifico come sia più
agio
molto bene dietro che non ci sperava
grandi ferma rancesco del sen
ed è a questa ragazza volete un parere
il blog ma lui è il nostro cugino che si
è laureato a discapito del fatto che il
vento dispettoso
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]
si chiede ma non solo
il giorno del signore che poi rimani
male
da questa prospettiva il brutto lo dico
da camera ma non è così
[Applauso]
bravo è la sua capacità di riprendere
sempre quello 20 secondi enrico a sua
insaputa appassionato accettato un
bicchiere di spumante linee che prima
era stato bevuto da gabriele comune di
gabinetto inquadra cabina e io dico
gabriele sul quadro cioè enrico avvenuto
in un bicchiere futuro
enrico ha bevuto in un bicchiere parlato
vicino ma come l'ha scoperto gli hanno
dato un pugno sul corpo tutte le la tesi
anche madri che cosa su collo e lui ama
frequentare i vampiri il nostro no il
buon nostro bello sono i cugini te lo
portiamo a natale perché siamo sempre
noi quindi il nostro regalo arriverà
questa è una capanna praticamente
diciamo che è una cosa che fate voi lo
sapete io l'ho detta tutta una vita che
l'aspettavo dopo che tu l'hai dichiarato
per me è stata una gioia a tutti c'è
niente di nuovo ma non diciamolo io anzi
e li abbiamo una persona che del nostro
campione di utenti
io a risi con uno zio ma enrico come dio
come zio non ho sentito dobbiamo parlare
vorrei parlare del busto di un p mio zio
dio dio
io sempre qui si sta bene in vicende in
questo ci troviamo praticamente la zona
pratici più o meno impossibile
parcheggiare impossibile cioè da tipo 20
minuti che stanno dicendo che brucia di
tanto che aveva detto dobbiamo non ho
però le cave dove siamo però che stiamo
facendo
siamo al nh hotel e stiamo per andare a
festeggiare paolo a mangiare sono senza
colazione senza pranzo quindi ci piace
in questa volta
non si può mangiare perché non arriva
paolo davvero che possa seguire
l'attuale l'attuale non partire
si segnala tecnica come siamo veramente
discreta che carini ragazzi negli occhi
faccio finta di venti libri
da guardare meno
io di roma 1 e 2
ho lasciato ingannare che profonda
anche servito quello che ha lasciato la
cosa a casa vostra che avete fatto
roma ma quale belle dame a me sto qui
con gabriele vorrei leggergli un
commento scrivono ma il nostro sensibile
signorile grazie guglielmo come
sopravvissuto per dire a un compagno di
stanza come gabriele durante
l'adolescenza e soprattutto come
sopravvissuto gabriele se stesso una
risposta tu non puoi capire calcola solo
che quando cambiamo casa io gabelle
scegliamo la stessa camera lui protestò
perché non voleva stare con me perché
avrei fatte mie forze comodi due mesi
dopo compra una canoa per attraversare
il mare di stracci che abbandonava in
mezzo alla strada in realtà io non sono
così come mi avete visto io ho fatto per
farvi divertire per fare un po di show
che non mangio così non bevo così buona
enrico segoni e continua a riprendere
casi siano sicuri che non mangi avete
appena visto il fratello di lavinia
quello che non sinistra erano per un
dato 9 intelligente cioè una torta a due
strati per cui appena finisco di servire
più uno strato l'inizio ha mostrato
mettono in olio zucchero a velo non ho
mai visto cane non so se perché vivo in
cambogia il rigo
smetti devo dire una cosa questa ragazza
non si fa vedere le franci mostrati per
la prima volta le telecamere così la
potete anche cercare su questa
bellissima ragazza è niente poco di meno
che
nostra cucina e un bacio d'amore è una
bravissima ragazza è pasticcera è una
gran [ __ ] questo panino
non vi è laureata la tappa il mestiere
più attivo del mondo con la palla a
tutte le persone che si laureano dico
sempre benvenuti nella disoccupazione
da qui sarà come ricominciare da capo
sto scherzando è prima è qualcosa
sottoscrive no sta facendo uno sforzo è
una burla
non ho preso una laurea non posso fare
delle battute sulle lauree senza che
cosa che sembri un rosicone senti ma voi
andrà a questa laurea di mezzo chilo in
vita forse mia mamma in un colore ma
invitati attesi però deviato
siamo scappati da quel covo di arancini
mamma mia in ritardo adesso perché
vorrei andare a pallavolo open a
dimettermi ha letto la palla con tutte
le reti se mangiate acosta che sin dico
io sto portando a casa enrico che noi
sta facendo anche lui fare tardi no sa
istituto buttare in mezzo a limone
essere fratelli vuol dire anche questo
del ser fardelli è un fardello è vero
che altro dire
a questo punto direi richiuderla qua il
mio look è stato apprezzato comunque è
stato definito dalla maggior parte delle
persone mafioso pimp di sace arancione è
l'arancino l'impanatura e niente ci
vediamo a questo punto domani ma harry
con un nuovo blog max perfetto ciao